what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime uproar and today i will be
looking into every s-class heroes
backstory from one punch man we have a
load of amazing s-class heroes to go
through and i am super excited for this
one now if you do enjoy these one punch
man videos on the channel you know what
to do smash that like button saitama
style if you haven't already make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications and while you wait for
more one punch man content on the
channel why not check out our huge one
punch man playlist that includes videos
on all the s-class heroes powers all
dragon and god level monsters and more
link to that is in the video description
and now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers and all
kicking these backstories off with none
other than the 17th ranked puri puri
prisoner this guy is an absolute unit
and unfortunately for us a lot of his
history is relatively unknown though we
do know a few details for one we know he
is in prison and why he is in prison too
puri puri prisoner was arrested at some
point during his hero work for unwanted
advances towards many men for his
inappropriate behavior out in the field
he is currently serving a 10 000 year
sentence
now thanks to the one punch man hero
encyclopedia it confirms that puri puri
prisoner wasn't his original hero name
and at some point it was changed we do
not know what the original name was or
when this some point was that his name
was changed through speculation the
inclusion of prisoner makes sense as to
his current situation thus we can
comfortably speculate that his arrest
was the reason behind this change
however the question remains about the
name as a whole was his name simply puri
puri before or was the whole name
changed it shall remain a mystery for
now
other than that we do have some random
information from the encyclopedia it
tells us that he took swimming lessons
as a kid now the rest of this guy's
backstory is a complete mystery so
let's move on
the 16th ranked tank top master is up
next and again a lot of this guy's
backstory is unknown we do know that the
origin of his hero name came from him
being a master who wore tank tops and
that he made the most of the tank tops
performance
tank top master claims that the tank top
that he wears boosts his strength
whether this is actually true or not has
not been proven now a fun bit of trivia
about tank top master before we move on
comes from the one punch man audio book
charanco learning it tells us the tank
top master actually makes his own tank
tops which can be bought from the hero
association's official merchandise
lineup
moving on to the 16th ranked s-class
hero bad better known by his hero name
of metal bat
one year prior to the beginning of the
current story we are familiar with metal
bat was a c-class hero and his rank was
223rd
through impressing the hero association
with many impressive performances
against demon level threats he moved up
to s-class and upon becoming an s-class
hero the hero association told bad that
they could arrange anything that he
wished listing examples that included
specialized weapons and it was
specialized weapons that really piqued
his interest as he requested a metal bat
that would never break and thus the
birth of his signature metal bat
his choice for this never breaking metal
bat was due to the fact that he would
previously use metal bats in combat
which seemed to be his personal
preference
however said bats he would use would
constantly break on him or i guess you
could say the villains he was fighting
against right
next up we have genos aka demon cyborg
the 14th ranked s-class hero
genocide's backstory is one of vengeance
and quite a dark one when compared to
the others that are on this list
jenno's was once an ordinary boy who
lived a happy life with his family now
at the age of just 15 a runaway rampant
cyborg attacked and destroyed his
hometown turning it into a barren ruin
not only was the town destroyed but the
crazy cyborg took the lives of everyone
including that of genocide's family
however genos himself was left as one
very lucky survivor
jenos however did not feel so lucky and
was left all alone in the town a weak
young 15 year old boy filled with the
burning desire for revenge
dr cuceno was tracking the berserk
cyborg and happened to pass by the town
he found genos and jenos begged the
doctor pleaded with him to turn him into
a cyborg himself so that he could have
the strength to extract his revenge dr
caseno agreed and jenos was reborn as a
cyborg whom fought for justice he
promised the doctor that one day he
would find and destroy the cyborg that
took everything from him
over the next four years jenos would
travel from town to town in search of
his vengeance defeating monsters and
evil organizations but was unable to
find the cyborg he was looking for
moving on to flashy flash the 13th
ranked s-class hero flashy flash is
known for his incredible speed and
proficiency with the sword flashy flash
hails from the ninja village and its
44th graduation class known as the end
the ninja village is a horrible place it
was a secret institution located in an
unknown city the sole purpose of this
place was in training highly skilled
ninja assassins
children under the age of 7 were sent
there to train for 10 years training in
the most ruthless of conditions a single
day for these ninja trainees was 72
hours long and they were only given 6
hours to sleep their food was tasteless
and all knowledge of the outside world
was completely cut off to them they were
forbidden from showing emotion and a
sense of brotherhood with each other the
instructors even said that if they were
to come face to face after graduation
they were to fight to the death flashy
flash himself described this place as a
hellish environment
now escape from this place was next to
impossible the only way out of here was
to complete the curriculum and earn the
permission to graduate after completion
of their training they were then sold
off to factories of the underworld now
flashy flash and speedo sound sonic were
the sole survivors of the 44th class a
class that was rumored to have been
failed products due to the mistakes that
were made during their training process
by the time flashy flash was 16 years of
age he became number one ranked after
choosing to stop hiding his own
abilities however his intentions were
not as the village thought flashy flash
had begun to execute his secret plan of
overthrowing the village administration
through his incredible skill he went on
a rampage and managed to do this he
killed the instructors staff and even
members of his own class anyone who was
a part of the village was to meet the
end and for some reason flashy flash was
unable to kill the leader of the village
now speeder sounds sonic was the only
survivor as the dream of overthrowing
the village was one shared by both him
and flashy flash flashy flash poisoned
sonic in order to save his life from
this onslaught
following flashy flash's departure of
the village many assassins were sent
after him but flashy flash defeated
every single one of them
moving on to the 12th ranked s-class
hero watchdog man
watchdog man was originally ranked 301st
and a c-class hero before being moved to
s-class when that was formed now not an
awful lot is known about watchdog man's
origins but it is said that he was based
on the japanese legend of hachiko
hachiko was an incredibly loyal akita
dog that was known for waiting for its
owner near the train station in shibuya
hachiko would leave their home and meet
his owner ueno after his commute from
work
however one day ueno suffered a cerebral
hemorrhage while giving a lecture in a
class he then died and never returned to
the station where hachiko was waiting
every single day for the next nine years
hachiko would return to the same spot at
that station awaiting his master's
return
of course he would never return but
hachiko began to gain the attention of
from those nearby who would bring the
dog treats and food whilst he waited for
his master approximately nine years of
this same routine sadly the dog was
found on a street in shibuya following
his death however the story of hachiko's
loyalty won the hearts of millions and a
statue was actually erected of him at
the same spot he would wait for his
master near that train station
so how does this tie in with watchdog
man i hear you ask other than the looks
being somewhat similar in terms of his
suit watchdog man also sits on a
monument near q city station similar to
that of hachiko's statue
next up is the 11th ranked s-class hero
super alloy dark shine
dark shine is completely different in
appearance to how he used to be in his
youth he was physically very weak and he
also lacked confidence
however on his 15th birthday he received
a pair of three kilogram dumbbells this
gift inspired and motivated him to start
training
years later this motivation paid off as
he became insanely strong being able to
lift two tons with just a single hand he
didn't just become extremely strong but
he also gained confidence and success
this is what inspired him to join the
hero association though he did star as
the lowest rank of the c-class which was
383rd however he eventually moved up to
s-class when it was formed due to his
hard work
also the said training he underwent was
also the origin of his hero name in
which he trained his body to be as hard
as steel and the fact that his dark
muscles gave off a beautiful shine
moving on to pig god pig god is the 10th
ranked s-class hero now unfortunately
pig god's origins are unknown so we
don't have any information on his
origins or his backstory the only
information i could find about him was a
bit of information regarding his hero
name thanks again to the one punch man
hero encyclopedia
the title of god was added to his hero
name by that of the hero association due
to the fact that they were impressed by
the description they had heard of him
they were told this man was like that of
a vindictive god thus they added this to
the name
next up we have drive knight he is the
ninth ranked s-class hero and again we
do not know all that much about his
origins and backstory
what we do know is that his hero named
drive knight was of his own choice
we also know that he had asked the hero
association to have his name changed to
drive knight at his own request however
what we don't know is what his hero name
was before this change
now on the topic of his name drive night
it is believed to be a reference to
batman and his name as the dark knight
this makes sense i guess in terms of his
name now the common traits he also
shares with batman is that the way that
they both have a habit of gathering
intel on their targets that and they
both rely on gadgets technical tools and
vehicles to take down the bad guy in the
most effective manner
okay zombie man is up next he is the
eighth ranked s-class hero
zombie man was created by dr genus in
the house of evolution
the house of evolution was an evil
organization founded by the doctor whose
goals was that of human perfection
through artificial evolution zombie man
himself was known as subject 66 and was
the only success the doctor had when
creating the immortal series
ten years ago we know that zombie man
managed to escape the destroyed lab
again the one punch man hero
encyclopedia tells us that zombie man
once fought a mysterious being for
140 hours
coming out of the encounter victorious
this fight is what made zombie man
famous
talking of faye moving on to none other
than king
king is the seventh ranked s-class hero
also known as the strongest man on earth
in his youth king won several video game
tournaments
now around the time period of one and a
half to three years ago he was attacked
by the octopus claw man who left king
with his trademark 3 scars on his face
during the attack king was saved by none
other than saitama who was training to
be a hero at the time
saitama actually went on to save king's
life in five more occasions but somehow
it would always end up in the same
result the king would unintentionally
get the credit for the defeat of these
monsters one of which being vaccine man
where king fell into the blood of
vaccine man near the incident so the
hero association saw this and decided to
capitalize on the reputation of king's
strength as such they made him an
s-class hero without him having to take
the hero examinator and through being
thrust into the public limelight as a
symbol king was dubbed as the strongest
man on earth
this theme continues with king where he
claims both money and reputation for
deeds he has not done himself as well as
this his hero name was given to him by
the hero association in honor of his air
quote strength when it came to defeating
a disaster level demon with ease somehow
king claimed the title
king of heroes
next up is the sixth rank s-class hero
bofoy also known by his hero name of
metal knight
again we have another s-class hero here
with a backstory that is relatively
unknown now we do know some origins of
his hero name thanks to the one punch
man data book his hero name metal knight
was a direct request from beaufort
himself as he believes his still robot
engages in the activities of peace such
as that of a knight i don't know about
you but this is definitely one of the
more ironic hero names as a knight
usually has the characteristics of being
you know chivalrous and want to have a
behavior that shows high morals and
standards
but with metal knight he's definitely
not these things he is more of a person
that is quite cold personality wise and
he also tends to deal with situations in
a more pragmatic nature and is pretty
much the direct opposite of what a hero
let alone a knight should be
don't you think
okay moving on to the youngest of the
s-class heroes and fifth-ranked child
emperor
child emperor is another hero whose
backstory hasn't been revealed to us all
we really know is from the one punch man
original web comic in which he and metal
knight had a somewhat history the web
comic tells us that sometime prior to
the events of the story child emperor
was once metal knight's assistant
it also tells us the child emperor once
fought and defeated all of atomic
samurai's disciples
however with that little knowledge on
this little guy
let's move on
kamikaze aka atomic samurai is next up
he is the rank 4 s-class hero one of the
most powerful heroes and a swordmaster
as well as being a member on the council
of sword masters
so before the founding of the hero
association kamikaze started a dojo it
was here that he approved only three
standout disciples who would work with
him as heroes moving forward
these three disciples were bushidrill
ian and okamaitachi
these three made the cut after an apple
cutting test pun intended by the way and
would join him in the hero association
kamikaze a master swordsman has the
ability to tell how a person lives or
has lived their lives by their ability
to cut using a sword and will only
recruit those worthy of passing this
test
now these three are all a-class heroes
however fubiki states that all of his
disciples should be s-class ranked and
that they aren't due to sweep masks
gatekeeping
moving on to bang aka silver fang the
martial arts master creator and teacher
of the water stream rock smashing fist
technique and the rank 3 s-class hero
in his past bang was a reckless and
violent guy who was involved with crime
he would constantly seek out and
challenge any strong opponent and would
put them in the hospital
his brother bomb was disgusted by his
brother's actions and decided to
confront him on this now before the
fight bomb had noted that his brother
thought he had gained extreme power
although he had not overcome himself and
this was the lesson he wanted to pummel
into his younger brother
bang ultimately lost the fight and
became enraged bomb told his younger
brother to call off before he left and
rightly so as this loss was the one that
taught bang the error of his ways and
made him really see the person that he
had become
seeing his errors bang followed in his
brother's footsteps and started a dojo
as well as this he started to create a
new defense orientated fighting style
over the years bomb would keep an eye on
his younger brother by visiting the dojo
he couldn't help but smile because of
his brother's new attitude his dojo was
passed down through generations as well
as the fighting style that he created
called water stream rock smashing fist
he created this star whilst training
under bomb and all of the scars that he
has now are from that time in which he
was trying to create this style
bang also took place in a super fight
tournament to promote his dojo and yeah
he won it many many students came from
bang's dojo but his most famous was his
top student
garu however one day whilst bang was
away garu went on a rampage through the
dojo injuring many of bang students when
bang found out about this he beat up
garu and banished him from the dojo this
rampage caused bang to lose all of his
students except for one charanco now
before the start of the series bang was
a b-class hero ranked 77th but was moved
into the s-class when it was formed
next up we have tatsumaki also known by
her hero name tornado of terror she is
rank two of the s-class heroes
now due to her psychic abilities
tatsumaki was taken away by scientists
from her adopted family at the age of
just 7 so that they could study her
powers her adopted family agreed and
were compensated for this with money
tatsumaki underwent tests by these
scientists who were looking into her
amazing powers for her compliance she
was rewarded with candy and toys however
she was always denied her requests of
going outside now when tatsumaki would
refuse to use her powers for the
scientists she was locked away in a cell
18 years ago when tatsumaki was aged 10
a monster outbreak occurred while she
was locked away in said cell this left
her alone and to fend off the monsters
herself however luckily for tatsumaki
she was saved by blast he introduced
himself to the young girl and asked her
why she didn't use her powers against
the monsters in order to save herself
tatsumaki lied to blast saying that they
weren't working but blast saw through
the lie he knew that she was holding
back her powers so that the scientist
would deem her useless and let her go
tatsumaki admitted to blast that this
was the case and also told him of her
heartbreak due to the fact that her
adopted parents had sold her out to this
fate
now somehow blast knew that tatsumaki
had a little sister
he told tatsumaki that he advises her
not to rely on someone to save her next
time and that she must become strong
herself in order to protect her family
now it was all because of blast and
these words that tatsumaki became a hero
okay final hero on the list is none
other than blast the rank one s-class
hero
unfortunately blast is another one of
those heroes where we don't know a lot
about his backstory or origins this is
largely down to the fact that blast
keeps all of his personal information
disclosed from the hero association
what we do know is of course the events
of 18 years ago in his involvement with
the young tatsumaki that we had just
talked about but other than that we do
not know much at all we do know that in
terms of his character it is said that
he is based on superman as the two share
quite a few traits such as their
character designs the fact that there's
so much mystery around blast's power and
according to fubiki blast can also shoot
laser beams from his eyes just like that
of superman which of course is a very
clear reference
and that is it every s-class heroes
backstory from one punch man make sure
to let us know in the comment section
below who your favorite s-class hero is
and which of the backstories you thought
was the best
if you enjoyed this one punch man video
and you'd like to see more on the
channel make sure to let us know by
smashing that like button saitama style
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one punch man videos
and while you wait for more one punch
man content on the channel why not check
out our huge one punch man playlist that
includes videos on all the s-class
heroes powers all dragon and god level
monsters and more link to that is in the
video description thanks again for
checking out the video we cannot wait to
see you in the next one until then
take care